[Musik]
hey was geht ab und jetzt willkommen bei
einem neuen video nach vier tagen oder
drei tagen es tut mir leid ich hab's ja
letztens schon gesagt ich hab echt sehr
sehr wenig zeit für youtube weil ich
eine menge lernen muss wie zum beispiel
würde auch wieder das ganze geht nach
ungefähr eine woche dann bin ich
eigentlich erst mal durch und habe dann
wieder genug zeit aber ich kann ja
grafik so viele videos machen trotzdem
habe ich mir aber vorgenommen dass jede
woche eigentlich mindestens so zwei-
oder videos kommen sollten also drei
wenn es gut läuft diese woche habe ich
heute noch gar keines geschafft aber wie
man sieht ich bin auf dem weg der
besserung
heute kommt ja das erste wenn ich heute
noch schaffen auf jeden fall folgendes
ich sitze ja eigentlich echt seit
gestern oder vorgestern jeden tag zum
nachmittags am schreibtisch bin am
lernen und am lernen hier sehr sehr
interessante studien ist wirklich
richtig richtig geil
ich habe mir dann irgendwie gedacht hey
du kannst doch ein video machen und
lernen miteinander verknüpfen weil die
kennt ihr bestimmt selber alle wenn man
lernen dann kann man auch mal dabei was
essen süßigkeiten essen was leckeres
trinken und so weiter und wenn man so
schön der laptop ist dann guckt man ja
ab und zu auch mal das eine oder andere
youtuber wieder dabei und deshalb
abgelenkt und gestern habe ich zum
beispiel im video gesehen da ging es
darum da hat jemand eine amerikanische
pizza gemacht und ich fand diese pizza
sei eigentlich ganz lecker aus und ich
habe mir gedacht er wohnt in köln als
wenn es hier nicht irgendwo
amerikanische pizza gebe deswegen geht
es im heutigen video einfach mal darum
amerikanische pizza größte italienische
pizza also die standard pizza die
eigentlich jeder kennt weil ich muss
ehrlich sagen so eine richtige
amerikanische pizza also wirklich so
eine richtig fette pizza habe ich selber
noch nie probiert und ich bin gespannt
wie es schmeckt ich hoffe euch krieg was
vernünftig ist ja dann vergleichen sie
einfach mal mit einer italienischen
typischen pizza hat mir schon mal ein
bisschen rum geguckt und das sind
irgendwie die einzigen anbieter die hier
in amerikanische pizza liefern deswegen
habe ich dann noch weiter gegoogelt und
bin fündig geworden sicher dass gerade
bei einer amerikanischen pizza factory
angerufen und die machen jetzt
amerikanische
seit ich nachher abholen kam wie
bestellt jetzt doch die italienischen
pizza einfach hier über lieferando hin
und dann hoffe ich sind die beiden
ungefähr zur gleichen zeit da und wir
können einfach mal probieren ich bin
gespannt worden auch die amerikanisch
spitze ihr könnt ja meine kommentare
schreiben habt ihr so was schon mal
probiert und dann würde ich sagen wir
sehen uns jetzt sofort im auto wieder
weil ich mal eine pause gönnte ich immer
einlegen bis gleich hast du die leute
wissen zudem sind bei diesem auto
nun ist auch zerbrechen irgendwie habe
ich einfach gemerkt
draußen ankommt
wenn ich nach der geburt nicht wissen
hat er aber auch nicht weiter
ausgestellt das blöde es jetzt nur
pizza bestellt ich jetzt eigentlich
nicht kostet ab und kann
die bei uns ankommt
wenn man keine wahl
jetzt werde ich auch noch anbieten
ja hallo ich habe keine beziehung
bestellt
[Musik]
du weißt du noch
wir fahren jetzt mit der bahn sitzen
bleiben muss man vielleicht bekommen
eine stunde später weil es dauert nicht
so lang und nichts anderes übrig habt
noch eine freundliche der anschluss
könnten
aber der ist erst zwei stunden da
mit 14 treffern
die pizza isst dann später event wollen
ganze aufwärmen
sonnenschein
[Musik]
pizza lieferanten abstrakt
haben keinen job gefunden
[Musik]
noch mal daumen hoch wollte soweit wir
sind jetzt wieder zurück in unsere
wohnung allerdings im treppenhaus
brüssel kommt in der stunde
so sieht allerdings die pizza aus mega
geil wir sind ein bisschen kalt ich bin
mal gespannt ich musste ja jetzt mal
wieder ein bisschen aufwärts
wir haben gerade über lieferant nur
einfach noch mehr die italienische pizza
bestellt also die kommt jetzt vielleicht
so einer halben stunde also ich hätte
wirklich schon längst fertig sein
gültige video zu anderen blog eine
stunde unterwegs nur diese pizza soll
eigentlich noch leben hat naja egal wir
sind gleich wieder okay leute werden
auch eine stunde bevor die jetzt ganz
kalt ist ich wollte euch einmal zeigen
geldes aussieht eigentlich eine pizza de
france ich finde das eigentlich auch
viel geiler wert ist einfach hier ist
käse drauf darauf dass käse und dann
müssen wir noch mal käse und und nach
markt
also fest aber ich bin so alexander herr
leute person und systemhaus man kann
einfach zu sagen durch die entwicklung
komplett untypisch
also wenn ihr wirklich ein richtiger
käse freund seit dann ist das eine menge
zeit und da muss man auf jeden fall mal
amerikanische pfizer probieren natürlich
schmeckt so irgendwie überhaupt nicht
wie italienische pizza also also die
pizza die man kennt wenn wir die
gleichen einander liegen haben dann
sieht man auch locker den unterschied
und man muss sagen das ding hat zwölf
euro kostet und ich mein so was ist das
jetzt auch nicht also warten jetzt noch
gleich bis die andere pizza kommt dass
sie jetzt auch noch der letzte so
langweilig hier das sowas eigentlich das
ja eigentlich lernen wollte also ich
meine lockerheit schon drei stunden
verschwindet sechseinhalb stunden später
leute wir sind endlich wieder hier das
ding ist nur irgendwie die andere pizza
ist immer noch nicht da also das dauert
jetzt schon lange was ein anstrengendes
video endlich was geht da gar kommen
hoch ja leute eine wirklich ganz ganz
stinknormale so leute also wir haben
jetzt hier ich habe die amerikanische
pizza im ofen geholt damit ihr halt
einfach in ein bisschen warm wird ich
würde sagen wir tun jetzt einfach zwei
stücke nebeneinander also ich bin
ehrlich ich bin wirklich voll überzeugt
von diesem amerikanischen einfach weiß
weiß nicht vielleicht liegt sein weiß
zum ersten mal ist und dass alle so
kenne habe also käsig und so das ist
echt geil
also also das hier ist einmal die
amerikanische mega geil mega fertig und
wahrscheinlich auch fünfmal so ungesund
und die haben wir ein stück italienische
pizza ganz traditionell wenn man das
eigentlich kennt ziemlich dünn ganz
stossen margarita kennt jeder hat jeder
schon vergessen so leute nach wirklich
jetzt also wir haben jetzt 18 30 ich
habe mit dem velo glaube ich schon 15
mal angefangen ich dachte so ja kommen
16 30 sollten weiter pizzen da sein
allerspätestens habe ich jetzt
eigentlich auch mal geschafft also wie
man hier sehen kann ein ganz klarer
unterschied ihr könnt ihr mal kurz in
die kommentare schreiben also hier auf
der rechten seite von euch und auf der
linken seite von euch das hier ist die
amerikanische pizza dass die
italienische die klassische pizza welche
sieht eure meinung nach besser aus
schreibt in kommentare also meiner
meinung ganz klar die amerikanische
politik heraus weil man auch noch dass
wir mit dem käse jetzt mal der direkte
vergleich
ich weiß man erst mal noch hier rein
also wie schon gesagt wenn ihr käse mit
probiert das auf jeden fall mal mega
geil hier ist ziemlich viel gehört drauf
also man muss natürlich sagen das
schmeckt auch keinen fall schlecht nur
ich weiß nicht also ich bin irgendwie
echt ich mag käse richtig gerne und ich
bin hier von vielmehr überzeugt gerade
als fan einer klassischen pc ich weiß
nicht also ich muss sagen ich bin echt
positiv überrascht das hier ist auf
jeden fall die dickste pizza die ich je
gegessen habe ja eigentlich war es auch
der sinn dieses video ist das einfach
mal zu probieren steckt mega gut
kann ich euch allen empfehlen natürlich
sind die geschmäcker unterschiedlich
aber probiert mal amerikanische pfizer
wenn ihr irgendwie die chance dazu haben
sonst würde ich sagen was daumen nach
oben da wenn ihr mitleid mit uns hatte
dass wir leider aus gesperrt waren wir
sehen uns natürlich in dieser woche noch
mal wieder ich weiß noch nicht genau
wann aber wir nicht vergessen und ja das
war vereint